just start by telling us some good news  that there's some sort of spin-off with  you in it on madman Jones spinoff  what can you tell us about that I knew I  was on to something I don't even I don't  think there's actually any rumor out  there of us but up but we just wanted to  happen oh yeah I dream about it every  night you do yeah possibility what are  you gonna miss most about playing John  assuming there is no spin-off I know I  missed her everyday already it's already  been over a year since we wrapped and  the nice thing is that people are still  enjoying the show and watching it so  daily people come up and say something  nice about the show so I get to like  still have those memories and live with  her for a long a long time so I miss her  though  we all do